it's one of those sequels that's been
rumored for years Goonies - the latest
surge of Goonies hype happened in 2014
when director Richard Donner confirmed
that the long-awaited sequel was indeed
going ahead but so far nothing
unfortunately for Goonies everywhere a
sequel becomes increasingly unlikely
with every passing year here's why we
never got to see The Goonies - the
scripts have sucked in 2009 Empire
magazine conducted an interview with all
of the original Goonies as well as
director Richard Donner and producer
Steven Spielberg and naturally the
interview soon turned to talk of a
sequel Donner was quick to blame the
lack of a decent screenplay for the
film's constant stalling telling Empire
that he and Spielberg had spent a lot of
energy hunting for a good script and
that the duo had many meetings with
writers but nothing stuck cast member
and weird modern vampire Corey Feldman
was more positive about the prospect of
a second Goonies outing though Donner
didn't share his enthusiasm stating
there was no hope of it going ahead at
that stage even Feldman who doesn't have
much going on right now except for
whatever this is knows that Goonies 2 is
a dangerous game to play saying it could
have a very bad backlash at the end of
the day and I've said this before the
only way a goonie sequel happens and is
forgivable to the fanbase is if it is
done right Feldman and co-star Sean
Astin even wrote a sequel themselves and
presented it to Richard Donner but we're
told that their ideas were too expensive
considering how much cash goes into
blockbusters today and the fact that
animated prosthetics and a giant pirate
ship weren't too cost-prohibitive for
the original it's hard to imagine what
Feldman had asked and turned in that was
deemed too extravagant but either way
Astin is game yes or no Goonies sequel
someday I hope you in what they want me
yes yes and everyone knows an angry Al
Roker will not be denied
The Goonies - producer Frank Marshall
has gone on record as saying that he
won't make a sequel just for the sake of
doing it
insisting that the story has to be right
before the film can go ahead to avoid
disappointing fans ironically fans ended
up being disappointed by another one of
his comments a reboot instead picture
this a bunch of middle aged Goonies have
lost touch with what it means to be a
member of the team leaving their
children to revive their never-say-die
attitude and take them on a new
adventure it writes itself
right Frank Marshall doesn't quite see
it that way the producer revealed that
any new Goonies project would not
actually be a sequel but a film made in
the Amblin spirit of Goonies so
unfortunately for those hoping for a
continuation of the story the idea of a
complete reboot has been supported by
the writer of the original movie Chris
Columbus despite previously stating that
the only way the film could be done was
with the original kids as parents
Columbus has since changed his tune
confirming that he's currently on a full
nostalgia attack and actively involved
in reboots of both the Goonies and
gremlins look there are a lot of writers
who are interested in writing Goonies
but the problem is that we're very
protective because it's a such a
well-loved movie the same goes for
grandmas grandma's is a little easier
because that worked out so well for
ghostbusters Richard Donner is getting
older as someone who's keen to see this
long-awaited sequel eventually happen
Feldman has raised fears that the
project is very much time-sensitive
saying Richard Donner is 87 years old
and it's like no one really wants to
make it without him he's the driving
force behind it he says it's still alive
but as we all know when you get to that
age things slow down quite a bit there
is a big possibility that he might not
want to keep driving it Feldman went on
to explain that Goonies too just
wouldn't happen without Donner in the
director's chair adding that every day
that passes without the wheels in motion
takes us a day closer to it never
happening chunk out even if Goonies 2 is
a sequel they would have been forced to
do it without one of the most loved of
all the Goonies
geoff cowan the former child actor who
played chunk nixed the idea of returning
claiming that his new career as an
entertainment attorney and author is too
good to give up even if he does remember
his acting days fondly anybody who says
they intentionally give up acting is
lying
they're absolutely lying you know I love
me a kid actor it was great
but you know for me I look different I
was evolving from chunk to hunk that I
am today
Cohen has become one of the go-to
attorneys in Hollywood has written a
book called the deal makers ten
commandments and the ex gun II also
occasionally writes about legal and
political matters for CNBC so he
probably doesn't have enough time to do
the old truffle shuffle anymore Goonies
go off-broadway evidently fed up with
waiting for a sequel to be greenlit
Donner went ahead and made alternate
arrangements to bring the Goonies back
to life in 2015 the director announced
that he was creating an off-broadway
immersive production of The Goonies he
outlined his vision to Yahoo movies
explaining there's no seats the venue is
you go into a warehouse and there's
something happening in that warehouse
and that's the play you've come to see
only you become part of it and you
travel through with actors The Goonies
play has yet to materialize with no
details to speak of Donner was adamant
that the show would soon be a reality
however and while this would surely be
an unforgettable experience for any
Goonies fan Donner focusing on this
project means Goonies to is as far off
now as it's ever been
the closest we'll ever get is a
notoriously weird Nintendo game
but never-say-die right don't say that
never say that Goonies never say die
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to